[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i had a friend who uh
former nfl player he realized that we
would have nate burlson on he goes
you gotta ask nate about buying fake
jewelry and i go
wait nate bought fake jewelry yeah he
goes yeah he spent money in his first
contract
and i think he bought uh a car maybe
bought his parents something
and uh but he bought fake jewelry
because he thought well nobody would
know
that you had fake jewelry because hey
you're a pro and you're making some good
money here
you're being smart with your money nate
burlson on loan from uh
cbs sports also nickelodeon nate uh is
that true that you had fake jewelry with
your first contract
yes that is very true first let me say
uh thanks for having me on i appreciate
it
um yeah definitely when i first got in
the league there were
priorities and it was um paying down
certain bills that my mother and father
had making sure that we were secure in a
couple of homes that i wanted to buy for
them
you know make sure my wife was taken
care of then when it came to me
i knew that i wanted jury but i also
wanted jewelry
more for the look of it and i was buying
jewelry because
i thought it looked cool on me so in my
first
contract i was going down to new york or
any bootleg swap meet
and give me something shiny that you
couldn't tell the difference
if it was real or fake now at 39
you know i buy jewelry for different
reasons i don't buy it because i want
people to see it
i buy it because i really like it and i
think that's the difference between
young nate burleson and old nabroson at
this age
whatever i buy i do it for myself and
most of the time i buy it
not to wear it just so i can have it and
i appreciate it
you should go to the rookie symposium
and tell those rookies hey you're going
to get money
do do the right thing for your family
but save your money there's nothing
wrong with fake jewelry
you're right about that listen i'll tell
these guys in a heartbeat you know if
you get a contract one
invest it um properly and know what
you're investing in so you're going to
have to educate yourself
save more money than you spend go ahead
and buy you some land because
they don't make that anymore and forget
about all the fancy stuff the car that
depreciates off the lot
and the diamonds that you can buy three
contracts from now so
uh there's always time to spend money on
stupid stuff how about you make stupid
money
and then buy stupid things see it's that
kind of uh
logic down to earth fatherly advice that
came through on nickelodeon
because that broadcast was so much fun
i tuned over and then i didn't tune back
in to
jim nance and tony romo and i was
wondering because you have kids
does it help you in explaining things as
you did to a younger audience on
nickelodeon
it does it does you know when i first
got the news uh i went home and over
dinner i was talking to my kids i have a
16 year old little nate
14 year old nehemiah and a 10 year old
that's my baby girl mia pearl
and um i was asking them about the new
nickelodeon shows that i might not be
hip to because i'm i'm familiar with the
old school stuff
you know the the double dares and and
all those different shows like rugrats
but um the new era shows i wasn't caught
up on as much as i
i needed to be and then i i wanted to
figure out
you know to be honest like what's hip
like what are kids saying
you know there's going to be moments
where i'm the older guy i know that
that's my specific role in this
broadcast
but i don't want to be too far out the
loop where it seems like i'm trying hard
so
i just wanted to make things relatable
and and i didn't want to talk down to
a group of young fans that are smart
enough to understand what i'm saying
this wasn't football for dummies this
was just football for a larger
demographic you know and i wanted to
talk
to the five-year-old and also the
50-year-old you know i wanted to i
wanted to bring up
how mr trubisky was benched during the
season and then comparing that
to being grounded and i'm pretty sure
everybody at home is like oh that makes
sense
and then what was great about noah eagle
who is a chip off the old block
as soon as we start talking about
mitchell trubisky and them not letting
him throw the ball in the game
he says nate he might be off restriction
but i don't think
naggy quote unquote his parents are
letting him leave the yard and i thought
that was great it's like yeah
they need to let him leave the yard let
him throw the ball down field that's the
only way they can get back in this game
so um a lot of the stuff that i was able
to do
and explain it landed but also cole
commet
the uh tight end you know he threw the
ball and you you talked about emotions
and dealing with your emotions there and
got the the best of him you said you
know use your words
yeah yeah it it it was like every
parent uh every teacher every
guardian every older person that is
giving me a a
a quote or some type of cliche i i used
it
and it was all fitting in the moment and
it was it was the perfect
broadcast for me you know i was born in
the 80s raised in the 90s influenced by
the 2000s so
a lot of who i am um it comes out
naturally you know a guy that can weave
in
music and movies and pop culture and all
the little things that make me unique
while explaining that on a daily basis i
just got off just got done with a three
hour show
and you know dropping a pop culture
reference isn't my way of staying
relevant
it's my way of communicating which made
this broadcast for nickelodeon special
he's nate burlson uh i think you spent
11 years in the nfl does that sound
right yeah
he's one of the hosts nfl network's good
morning football which airs monday
through friday
starting at 7 a.m eastern also part of
the nickelodeon broadcast with the
bears and the saints a couple of nfl uh
items here to talk about if you were the
gm
of the texans what would you do with
desean watson
you got to keep them you can't let a guy
like that
um leave your facility don't don't work
out some type of trade and get draft
picks or
trade for another qb there's a lot going
on right now and emotions are high
one i i felt like you know when deshawn
watson signed this long-term deal
he was probably thinking to himself i'm
gonna be
the qb that is involved in every
decision moving forward
um and now it's okay for him to think
that um is it
is it a necessity for a quarterback to
be involved in decision making no
and to be honest in most situations um
it isn't the case
but if you trade away deandre hopkins
and you know that the face of the
franchise
was jj watt and is now deshaun watson jj
watt will soon be done in a few years
you have to make sure that you make your
quarterback happy
and look at what he had to deal with
this year with the injuries
deandre hopkins being going will fuller
being suspended because of peds i
believe it was
and he still was just spectacular and
in every game fighting to the fourth
quarter so
you want to keep that type of talent
around bring in somebody like eric b
enemy
i i don't know what it is about eric b
enemy not landing a head coaching job
but if you can bring in a guy that can
mimic that kansas city chief's offense
with a quarterback like deshaun watson
they'll be in good shape
i was surprised that they let desean
in on the process or told him he'd be
involved in it that that's where i think
they made a mistake
because we've seen franchises that have
hall of fame quarterbacks who are not
involved in the process
if you're going to bring him in then
listen to what he has to
say or don't ask him and i thought that
that's where they made a mistake but
this is a messed up organization to
begin with
uh you know when you think they're
bringing in a gm that that quarterback
doesn't want
now who's their coach going to be you're
not going to hire the guy that he
probably wants in there
and i don't think jj watt is there next
year they used to be a formidable
defensive team
i i don't know i look around if i'm
deshawn watson i go
i don't want to be around here i love
houston then i don't love
playing for the texans yeah and it's
unfortunate because jj what at one point
this season said the same thing there
were rumors that he wanted to be gone
um deshaun watson obviously he's he's a
little bit upset
and more likely just exhausted with
everything that's going on but
you know here's the thing now when i
came in
whatever happened in the front office
players didn't know about it was there
was a distinct
disconnect and we were okay with it
that's just how it goes right
we're here to play football you cut us
to check we'll go do we need to do to
win games
we hope that you guys do everything when
it comes to scouting the draft
free agency and you help add to our team
nowadays because guys are getting
plucked from so many different areas
some guys are more novice than others
and i'm talking about front office staff
coaches um they're always looking for
the new face the young face
you might have to collaborate with your
quarterback
because these qbs are different they're
a lot smarter they've been playing
football for a long time if you're matt
lafleur you go to
green bay you're going to want to you're
going to want to
connect with aaron rodgers you're you're
going to want to collaborate with him on
what's best for the team
if you're at bruce arians as long as
he's been around the resume that he has
he wants to collaborate with tom brady
and appreciate
what he knows and then try to apply that
to the offense i do feel like there's a
new wave coming
of gm's and coaches that are looking at
these quarterbacks saying
all right how much do you want to be
involved because if you do want to be
involved in the process
then we will allow you to because i got
to be honest with you and you know this
it's just like tv there might be a coach
that comes in that doesn't know half
what the quarterback knows
there might be a producer that joins
your staff and as much as you can
appreciate where they came from or where
they are plugged from
they don't know half as much as you know
so at that point what do you do
are you a complete jerk and say and this
is my way or the highway or are you
saying hey
i'm gonna listen to what you got to
bring to the table but let me show you
what i have
and let's figure out the best game plan
to give the best show or to be the best
team
what's it like to play in a game where
you don't have confidence in your
quarterback
like you may like him but he's not good
it's the worst it's the worst because um
you know
you're i remember being in a huddle and
our quarterback got hit and we're
sitting in there
and at this point we knew that it was
going to be tough for us to gain some
momentum because our qb had the whites
of his eyes showing
he wasn't making eye contact with us and
as he's trying to get this play out he's
like
uh the slot right slot right uh
and once he gets nervous he did this
like nervous cough of clearing his
throat
instead of getting in a huddle and
looking at us dust himself
off saying all right hey listen listen
all right we just took a shot we're good
man don't worry about it i know what
second and 15
who cares you good you good i'm good
let's go here we go slot right
989 on one that's cool that's what we
want
but when you have a qb that um looks
defeated
um his body language is bad and he can't
even make eye contact
with you and the season has been going
down down down
all year long you're in that huddle
defeated as well
because you're you know you can get to
the line of scrimmage and do everything
that you're paid to do
i'm gonna get off the ball quick release
move all right i'm stacking on top i'm
gonna make a move at the top
right open here i am and then you're
looking at you you know
you know coming out of that break your
qb is either scrambling for his life or
he's on the ground
but you got to keep your head up and you
know the way that i was brought in
you don't show up in that locker room
telling everybody how bad the qb is or
how you need to have more confidence or
how better plays need to be called i
don't know i i come from an era where
you just you zip it up and you don't
complain we get paid to deal with the bs
so i love how every guy who's going to
mimic a wide receiver coming off the
line of scrimmage does that a little
that if that's all it took nate i could
have been all pro if i it's just that
little shape
just that little shake there i don't
even have to get up and i can do that
shake there
um one more item kind of looks like
you're constipated
i just read off an article in usa today
a column talking about the five things
to be concerned about with devonta smith
in the nfl
can you believe there's five things that
we should be concerned about with
devante smith going into the nfl
really i i i am shocked
that somebody would write an arc like
are these a legitimate
five things are these on the field fight
yeah it's like yeah so there's
durability oh my gosh
61175 who cares okay you don't care
about
that listen i'm watching this game and
i'm watching this game with my son
who is about six two and he's he's a
buck fifty soaking wet
um he's a sophomore in jersey um and um
he's quite the talented wide receiver
and we're looking at this guy in a very
very similar frame
and i i was blown away i just kept
saying i said man if trevor lawrence
wasn't the number one
overall pick this dude would go number
one overall like as a wide receiver
and my son's like really think he's that
good and i'm like yeah no he's
he's damn near unstoppable and why is it
it's a combination of a lot of things
um he's fast he has really good hands
great placement with his hands when
there's traffic
um two he's a tremendous route runner
and that's rare
there's a lot of guys that will last six
seven years in this league and they only
can run three routes
and and if you pay attention to some of
your favorite players
you'll notice like damn they are pretty
much one trick ponies
and on top of that they use them in
multiple ways now he's gonna have to go
to a system where
um you can move him around a little bit
but the variety in which
they use him outside inside put him in
motion
they literally ran uh the same play back
to back and scored on back-to-back plays
they just
flipped it and ran it opposite ways so
he can do it all
and that's why he's going to be good i
was sitting back saying
and if i'm the jets they're sitting at
number two i mean why not
why not get you a pure number one wide
receiver because
with how he played and what he was able
to do on that field in that stage in the
first half
and the heisman trophy and the 20 plus
touchdowns this is a dude that's gonna
come in
right now some of these rookies are
gonna take some time you look at
henry ruggs a little up and down jerry
judy with the broncos struggling to
catch the ball
there's certain guys where you're like
all right it's gonna take you a little
bit of time to catch a rhythm and really
start to gain confidence
it's not the case with d smith this dude
is gonna but here's some of the other
ones can
he be a batman or is he a robin now
these are these were five things brought
up by an nfl writer in usa today can he
be a batman or robin
uh explosiveness came up
can he be the same kind of explosive
player
in the nfl and so i
he became batman this year everybody
knew he was going to get the ball
because
waddle got hurt the explosiveness there
is still that gear that he has
as you know he gets to top in speed
as quick as fast as anybody that i've
seen
except for maybe tyreek hill so i don't
know
like where's the question mark on
explosiveness
don't be fooled by the long legs
in the easy stride my nickname in high
school was cadillac and i used to get
offended by it
and one of my coaches said no it's not
it's not because you're long and slow
you may think a cadillac is long and
slow what we're saying is
you're smooth and you got speed and you
can pick it up at any time
and you're in your your effortless in
and out of your breaks and i embraced
that nickname once i got to college
he is he's he's he's like a smooth
vehicle
and the thing is like you know he he
made a decision
to let these other guys that might have
had a little bit more hype
into the draft he could answer the draft
but he held on to the right time
and that's what makes him even more
dangerous is the fact that
he spent four years polishing up his
craft
and and he can he can beat you man
coverage there's a reason why he's open
by two or three yards when one guy's
guarding him he could beat you when
there's zone coverage
and as far as durability stefan diggs is
about
six foot i mean he might be about a buck
85
maybe buck 90 i'm not sure but stefan
diggs isn't the biggest
receiver in the world but he's the best
receiver in all of football this year
so now if you're saying well i don't
know if he has the strength and he looks
a little slight
okay so if he's done this in four years
working on alabama which i know
alabama's a beast they prepare like pros
what happens when he when he gets that
grown man strength you know what happens
when you go through those grown man
situations you know i'm saying you know
you start paying grown man bills
you get a little bit stronger you know i
like when real life hits you you get a
little bit stronger your mustache starts
coming in
jess gets hairy what happens when he
hits his mid-20s in real life hits him
and then he's out there playing he's not
playing for a turkey sandwich at the
cafeteria at alabama
he's playing for a million dollar check
that's a different marvin harrison was
six foot 179
at the combine there and that's what i'm
saying but also i
you know my thing with devonta smith is
you talk your or any draft pick you
talk yourself out of a pick because you
look at the
negatives and that's why i always say i
don't understand that if your positives
outweigh your negatives
then that's what you have to focus on
not you know what i don't know if he's
strong enough or like
that's where it gets dangerous and i
think that's what the bears probably did
with desean watson you know he's kind of
slight and i don't know if he can hang
you know mahomes seems like he wants to
be bred far
let's get this conservative mitchell
trubisky guy who looks like he's durable
and he can play and he's athletic
you talk yourself out of this and i
think that's the dangerous part of this
and how many how many teams talked
themselves out of drafting lamar jackson
oh i know because they said like he
can't throwing the baltimore ravens yeah
they picked him up in the first round
they got him at the last pick hey it's
great to talk to you congrats on the
success
and even extra as i uh i watch extra
every night just because i want to check
in on billy bush make sure he's behaving
but uh i i keep my
i keep him in check he's good to go yeah
actually i'm tuning in to watch his uh
co-host yeah yeah yeah jennifer yeah
no not you oh jennifer
taylor yeah yeah yeah
um thank you nate we appreciate your
time as always of course
great job that's nate burlson he's got a
lot of jobs there he's extra
he's a nickelodeon he's cbs pregame show
nfl network good morning football